Every topic, whether it be a note,
question, or
poll, allows followups down below.
You can reply to a topic
by clicking here, or
reply to a followup by clicking below.
If the topic is a question,
you can also edit the student answer.
This is a collaborative wiki,
where students can put together
an answer to the question.
So if you're providing the one
right answer to a question,
you may want to add it here.
If you're just posting
a further question or
a general suggestion that isn't
necessarily the one right answer,
it might be better to
post it as a followup.
>> One of Piazza's interesting features
is that instructors can endorse
student answer.
As an instructor one of my favorite
experiences is signing on to Piazza,
seeing a bunch of open questions,
but being able to go through and
just endorse student answers.
Because students have already answered
the questions for each other.
It's much more satisfying to me to
see students answering each other's'
questions and helping each other out,
rather than everyone relying on
the instructors and TAs for everything.
With the kinds of students and the kinds
of classes we have in the OMS program,
I never hesitate to say that I
think you'll learn more from your
classmates than you'll
ever learn from us.